we're pushing a little further on this
idea of simple harmonic motion we just
thought about in very simple terms
yesterday and now we're going to see if
we can understand some of the
intricacies of it especially when we
think about it in slightly different
circumstances okay now to begin it
always helps we're in applications of
calculus to the physical world it always
helps to have a picture in your mind of
what this is right now we talked about
some of the examples before like I'm
heartbeats and tithes and that kind of
thing but particularly I want to go
after the idea we developed yesterday I
think that the most important crucial
idea that we got was pretty swell is it
for a differential equation of simple
harmonic motions right so instead of
expressing acceleration in terms of time
we said we could express it in terms of
displacement what was the equation
negative and squared X right now what we
interpreted that to mean is that the
further away you are in one direction
the more you're being pushed in the
opposite direction said it again the
further you are in one direction perhaps
you're positive right the more you're
being pushed in the other direction
negative right and vice versa okay so we
had the wine glass for rates of change
and we have the tennis ball for a
straight-line motion so I thought okay
what's a picture what's the i can give
you something for my everyday life where
the further you get away from something
the more you get pushed the other way
there's a bit weird actually I was
reflecting this I thought oh and physics
usually it's the other way around like
the further away you get from something
the force that's acting on you tends to
decrease right like say you know light
to your eye it's actually the inverse
square law you know the further away you
are the less attacked your gravity the
further away you are from something the
less it's pulling on you okay but then I
realized it actually is a very common
example that we have um actually I
brought one in my pocket actually about
three in my pocket I had to bring three
because I wasn't sure if one would break
on me um rubber bands we know how her
advance work right so if you have say
centre of motion he's my submission ok
left head and you have a particle okay
it's moving around I'm just thinking out
straight line right so the further the
further that the particle this here is
from the center of motion this hand
right the further away you are the more
you're being pulled in the other
direction right like I can you can see
how I'm being like a that's about as far
as I can go I'm kind of scared to snap
it but I'm also no that's wrong so
what's happening I'm close to or from
your perspective I'm further off to the
left right that might be negative right
so I being pushed as a force acting on
me accelerating me toward the right in
the positive direction and off I go now
what happens is as I get accelerated the
further I go in eventually I get to a
point like here what what force is
acting on my particle answer nothing
because I'm there and it's comfortable
right but the thing is I was I was
moving when I got to that point so I
shoot past the center of motion I go
back over to the other way right but
once i get to this side the opposite
thing happens right the further I get
this way the more I get pushed back
toward the center of motion and over and
over again right so I hope rather then I
mean the problem with with calculus is
thinking it's all letters right you need
a picture in your head for what does
this actually represent so the picture i
have my head is a rubber band i hope
that makes sense